Okay,
so today we're going to talk about
piaget
and piaget is a constructivist and a
constructivist is someone who's
attempting to answer the question,
where does your personality come from?
Now for piaget would be more something
like where do your models of the world
come from,
but his idea of model of the world is so
broad that it's perfectly reasonable to
use personality as a proxy,
so here's one of Piaget's initial
propositions.
The common postulate of various
traditional epistemologies.
Epistemologies are theories of valid
knowledge is that knowledge is a fact
and not a process and that if our
various forms of knowledge are always
incomplete and our various sciences
still imperfect,
that which is acquired is acquired and
can therefore be studied statically.
Hence the absolute position of the
problems.
What is knowledge or how are the various
types of knowledge possible under the
converging influence of a series of
factors?
We're tending more and more today to
regard knowledge as a process more than
a state.
Any being or object at sciences attempt
to hold fast dissolves.
Once again in the current of
development.
It is the last analysis of this
development and innovate alone that we
have the right to state it is a fact
what we can and should then seek is the
law of this process he present,
he puts in parentheses,
we are well aware of on the other hand
of the fine book by Thomas Kuhn on
scientific revolutions,
the first aim of genetic epistemology,
because that's what he called his field
is therefore if one can say so,
to take psychology seriously and to
furnish verifications to any question
which each epistemology necessarily
raises,
yet replacing the generally
unsatisfying,
speculative or implicit psychology with
controllable analysis to know means to
act.
Human knowledge is essentially active to
know is to transform reality.
In order to understand how a certain
state is brought about knowing an object
does not mean copying it.
It means acting upon it.
Knowing reality means constructing
systems of transformation that
correspond more or less adequately to
reality.
Knowledge is a system of transformations
that becomes progressively adequate.
In fact,
if all knowledge is always in a state of
development and consists in proceeding
from one state to a more complete
inefficient one,
evidently it is a question of knowing
this development and analyzing it with
the greatest possible accuracy,
so here are the sorts of questions that
piaget addressed himself to.
They're very fundamental questions upon
what does an individual basis judgments,
what are his norms,
how is it that these norms are
validated?
What's the interest of such norms for
the philosophy of science in general,
and how does the fact that children
think differently affect our presumption
of fact itself,
more problems?
How did children conceptualized number
in space and time and speed?
How do they understand that objects
hidden from view or actually still
there?
How do they understand that entities
that can transform from one place to
another are the same entities.
How do we understand chance or moral
concerns,
play patterns and dreams are,
and how do we.
How is it that we imitate others and
what does it mean that we can?
Now,
here's a definition of constructivism.
This is from Piaget as well.
Knowledge does not begin in the eye and
it does not begin in the object.
It begins in the interactions.
There's a reciprocal and simultaneous
construction of the subject on the one
hand and the object on the other.
There is no structure apart from
construction,
either abstract or genetic
now,
so let's take some of that apart.
The first thing that piaget is pointing
out is that trying to understand what
knowledge is by referring to a body of
facts seems to be somewhat problematic
because facts shift with time and people
understand facts differently at
different stages of development.
Even though hypothetically we all live
in the same world,
it turns out that we can get by in some
sense with structures of knowledge that
differ from one another.
I think the easiest way to understand
that is actually to take something like
a pragmatic perspective and pragmatist
and I think piaget is a pragmatist and
pragmatic.
People basically say that because
they're interested in what constitutes
truth and of course we know that we
don't have absolute truth about
anything.
So the question is,
if you don't have absolute truth about
anything,
how do you know when what you know is
enough?
And the pragmatic answer to that is you
set your own conditions for truth with
each of your actions and the way you do
that is by specifying an outcome.
So if you tell a joke and now outcome is
that people should laugh,
you know,
even if 70 percent of the people laugh,
then that's probably good enough.
And so you could say that you've done a
good enough job of matching your social
knowledge to the circumstance to obtain
your desired end.
And so piaget's pig piaget's notions of
what constitutes knowledge,
valid knowledge structure seem to be
very,
very much pragmatic in origin.
And it's also partly because piaget is a
thinker who's who's deeply considered
the fact of human embodiment.
And in fact I think Psja has done that
more than any of the thinkers that we're
going to.
We're going to talk about.
And so for Piaget,
truth is determined inaction.
The next proposition is that when you're
trying to understand knowledge,
you should understand the process by
which it's generated rather than the
outcome of the knowledge process itself,
because the outcomes transform across
circumstances,
but the nature of the process that you
engage in to produce knowledge seems to
be constant across situations.
So,
and what is that process?
Well,
that's the,
that's the next part of constructivism.
Piaget you can think of for Piaget in
some sense,
the reality is a field of latent
information and interacting with that
information.
You cold some of it both physically,
physically and abstractly,
and out of that coding,
not only do you generate yourself,
but you also generate well,
if not the object itself,
so to speak,
at least your perceptions of the object.
So when you're continually engaged from
a pig and perspective and trying to,
uh,
trying to produce certain
transformations in the world and as you
produce them in an embodied sense
because you're acting in the world,
you map the transformations that occur
onto the transformations of your body.
And that mapping constitutes your
practical knowledge.
So for,
as I said,
for Piaget,
the body of knowledge that guides you is
always action predicated.
Now I want to provide you with another
way of understanding Pha so that as we
go through what he has to say,
we can not only understand what he has
to say,
but we can link it to the other things
that we're going to talk about.
Now.
There's a man named Jerome Bruner who
talked about narrative constructivism
and Bruner said,
we seem to have no other way of
describing live time.
Save in the form of a narrative.
So I'm going to review a little bit for
you what might constitute a basic
narrative.
And then I want to talk to you about the
way that narratives transformed because
one of the PSG and propositions is that
at a given time in development,
you might have a way of interacting with
the world,
say a Schema that is good enough for the
aims that you want to pursue at that
particular point in time.
But there may come a time when there are
transformations of one sort or another.
That could be specific to you or that
could actually happen in the world where
if you continue to perceive an act in
that manner,
you're not going to get what you want.
And so for example,
one,
here's an example from a developmental
perspective.
When you're eight years old,
it's probably okay for your mother to
arrange play dates for you,
but if that's still happening when
you're 15,
there's a problem and and so you,
you can see that the manner in which
someone interacts with the world,
even if it's successful at one point,
isn't necessarily successful in the next
and sometimes there are qualitative
transformations in the world.
That means that the structure that
you're looking at the world through has
to reconstruct itself to take in more
information and then you have to act out
that new body of knowledge that would be
accommodation from a pig and point of
view.
Piaget assumes that there's two things
happening when you're interacting with
the world.
One is that your current body of
knowledge is sufficient and all you have
to do is add to in a rail rather
normative way.
And if any of you know anything about
Thomas Kuhn,
that is roughly equivalent to Thomas
Kuhn's theory of normal science.
So normal science occurs when the body
of theory within,
again,
given scientific domain is quite
sketched out and what people are doing
is basically mopping up the details.
So you might say that,
uh,
right now in personality theory,
the psychometric big five models are
paradigmatic and what people are doing
is not so much arguing about whether or
not that structure exists,
but are arguing about something smaller,
which is what information can you derive
from the world?
If you take as your set of assumptions
that those five dimensions exist and you
can see that that's a less comprehensive
question than do the five dimensions
themselves exist.
So assimilation is when you have a
notion of how to act in the world so
that things happen the way you want them
to.
And you can just add more to that in an
accommodation occurs when instead the,
the novelty and the transfer formations
that you've encountered are so large
that you have to reconstitute the theory
itself in order to progress.
So for example,
in the example I used where when you're
eight or nine years old,
you can have play dates arrange,
but you can't when you're 15.
The reason for that is that you're
undergoing a series of maturational
changes,
a lot of a lot,
and a large number of them are
physiological and so you have to change
the assumptions that you use to deal
with the world.
And so one of the prime assumptions
might be when you're a child that it's
okay for one of your parents to serve as
a mediator of your social interactions,
but by the time you hit puberty,
then all of a sudden that becomes
inappropriate.
And if you continue to use the same
Schema,
then well then you're not well.
Then you're stuck at a developmental
stage that you shouldn't be stuck at.
That'd be roughly equivalent to Freud's
idea of a fixation to similar idea.
So
we're going to go back to this little
Schema here and I'm going to
recapitulate the idea that when you're
looking at the world,
this is a pragmatic frame of reference.
It's also a cybernetic frame of
reference.
And I think it's one of the easiest ways
to understand a head against Schema or
and the beginnings of a Schemata
Schemata,
sort of like an arrangement of Schemas
and schemas are like tools to deal with
the world and the tool that you're using
to deal with the world is the tool that
gets you what you want when you act it
out.
So here's some propositions with regards
to how those scheme is might be
formulated.
One is,
is that you're somewhere at some point a
and the next is you want some
transformation in the world to occur.
Otherwise you wouldn't be acting right.
So you have some vision of the outcome
that you wish to obtain.
And then you have a sequence of
behaviors.
At the most fundamental level of
analysis,
you have a sequence of embodied that you
can apply to the world and hopefully
that produces the transformation that
you want.
Now you can take a page from biology and
you can say,
well,
a lot of these schemas or brief
narratives are embedded in biological
systems.
So for example,
if you're hungry,
then that's going to set up a particular
Schema.
And if you're thirsty,
that's going to set up a particular
Schema and so on,
but human beings are capable of high
levels of abstraction so that instead of
pursuing direct biological goals,
we can perform operations that are in
some way conceptually linked to the
fulfillment of biological goals in a
social environment across large spans of
time.
Which is a much more complicated
question,
you know,
because I might say,
well,
why are you guys sitting here?
What does that have to do with
biological necessity?
And the answer is,
well in some sense it's rather tenuous
in that it's multiple stages removed
from absolute necessity.
But your hypothesis is instead of
foraging around in the frozen ground for
nuts,
it might be better to adopt a career
because that'll solve all of your
biological problems simultaneously.
And so again,
I'm going to repeat that.
So the animals problem is how to fulfill
a motivational state.
Will say your problem is how to fulfill
multiple motivational states in a social
environment that's composed of many
other people doing the same thing in the
short term,
the medium tournament in the longterm.
And you want to come up with a solution
that will satisfy all those constraints
simultaneously.
Now Piaget would regard as a solution
like that as an equilibrium state and
equilibrated state is,
this is a solution that isn't producing
anomalies,
are novelties when it's enacted in the
world,
and so it's important to understand this
because it forms part of the pig and a
theory of morality.
Now,
piaget,
he was a kind of a strange guy.
He was a childhood prodigy.
He was studying animals in depth when he
was a small child.
He published his first scientific paper
when he was 10,
which was on the behavior of mollusks,
and the next year he was offered to
curatorship of a museum in Switzerland,
but his parents,
given his developmental stage,
had to tell the people who wanted him to
take over the curatorship,
that he was only 11 and that it probably
wouldn't be appropriate.
Now,
when Piaget was an adolescent,
he went through what you might describe
as a messianic crisis.
He actually regarded messianism Zionism
as a developmental stage that often
characteristic characterized late
adolescence.
And so at that stage,
people are concerned with the
relationship between their individual
lives in the broader social community
and when he was in that mess scientistic
stage and very much concerned about
morality,
he was also suffering from a tension
between scientific and religious points
of view.
And one of the things that he wanted to
do as an adult was to reconcile values
with science or brought more broadly
speaking,
religion with science.
But we'll stick to values and morality
with science and I think he got farther
along on that than anyone else.
House.
And the state is one of his most
intelligent
proposition.
So an equilibrated state would be
something like.
It could be two things,
it could be you in a happy family and it
could be the happy family.
It depends on your level of analysis,
but you in a happy family are going to
be celebrated because assuming that
you're as happy as the rest of the
family,
what that means is that you found a
motive operation that simile tediously
works for you and for your family and a
higher order.
Equilibrated state would be happy you in
a happy family,
in a happy city,
let's say,
and so there are multiple levels of
potential equilibration and Piaget's.
One of Piaget's fundamental claims was
that I'd equilibrated state was
preferable,
so there's a value judgment there to a
disintegrated state and the reason for
that was that it took less energy per
unit of work to maintain an equilibrium
state.
So think about it this way.
So there's family and there's family B
and they're competing in a in a local
environment and family be as very
disharmonious.
And so in order for the family to get
anything done or any of the individuals
within the family,
there has to be a tremendous amount of
conflict.
And so the load is whatever they have to
do,
plus the conflict they have to go
through in order to do it.
And in many cases,
if the situation is disequilibrium good
enough,
then the conflict that you have to go
through to do whatever it is that you
want to do actually requires more energy
than the thing itself.
And so Piaget's point was that whereas
in a happy family will say,
and equilibrated family,
both the individuals and the family as a
unit can move forward without wasting a
lot of time in conflict.
And so piaget's idea was that,
you know,
in a,
in a race for success,
however you happen to define success,
the equilibrated system is going to
outperform the district deliberated
system because the district celebrated
system has to waste time and energy on
enforcement.
That's a lovely idea.
It's,
it's a profound idea because what it
does is it set up,
it sets up the preconditions for
starting to understand our value
judgements,
so to speak,
and value judgments are outcroppings of
theories of action because a theory of
action has to do with what you should
do.
And that's a value judgment.
Piaget would say that the,
the patterns of actually the value
judgements that lead towards a more
thoroughly equilibrated state are
better.
Now you can take that a bit further and
you can say that,
and this is sort of akin to piaget's
ideas that children go through stages of
development that are somewhat
identifiable cultures,
although there's a fair bit of debate
about that.
It's,
it's a quite as idea jetty and notion
that there only might be a finite number
of deliberated solutions to a set of
given problems.
So you can imagine,
well,
you pop up on the horizon,
you're born and you're a particular kind
of entity.
Now there are some things that you can
do as an entity to continue your.
Your existence as an entity and there's
other things that you can't do.
So you're bounded by a set of
limitations and possibilities.
One of the limitation seems to be is
that your family has to be sufficiently
well integrated so that you get a
certain amount of attention.
So for example,
if babies don't get a certain amount of
physical attention in the first year of
their life,
so nobody literally touches them and
plays with them,
then they'll often die because their
gastrointestinal systems will shut down.
And even if they don't die,
they're so impaired afterwards as a
consequence of that lack of initial
stimulation that they never recover.
And so you can see right off the bat
that one of the preconditions for even
for existence as a human being is that
you have to be born into a familial
environment that,
that has certain structures in place.
Now some of them are obvious like,
well,
you should be fed and you have to be fed
what you need to be fat and you have to
be protected and sheltered and,
and you know,
you have to be exposed to a certain
amount of information flow and so on.
So your physical,
obvious physical needs have to be taken
care of.
But then there are less obvious things
that you need from your local
environment,
like physical attention,
literally touch and play and social
interaction and language.
Because if any of those are lacking in
the initial developmental stages,
depends on the stage,
then you're going to be so crippled that
you won't be able to.
You won't be able to survive and thrive
in the world.
So then you can think that you know,
imagine that there's a set of
constraints that define the system
within which you can thrive as an
individual.
Then you might say,
well,
there's a set of constraints within
which a family can survive as a family
without blowing apart,
and then if you put multiple families
together in some sort of community,
there's a set of constraints that have
to be met for those families to live
together in relative harmony and so on.
All the way up the levels of complexity
and a properly equilibrated state,
as I said,
would be one where you're thriving in a
thriving family,
in a thriving community and so forth,
all the way up the all the way up the
chain of complexity.
So it's a very,
very,
very smart idea.
And you can also imagine that one of the
things that that means is that
representations of moral systems might
have some similarities across cultures.
Now we know this is true already because
there are a number of human universals,
but if take individuals and you put them
in geographical area a and you take
different individuals and you put them
in geographical area B,
because of the nature of the constraints
and the fact that there is some
relatively limited subset of solutions
that will satisfy everyone at each of
those levels of analysis,
you're going to expect relatively
similar moral systems to develop in
different cultures.
And so it's also a powerful argument
against moral relativism.
Now,
you know,
relativism is a tricky thing because you
know,
you can ask yourself,
well,
are people the same or are they
different?
And the answer to that is,
well it depends on what you mean when
you ask the question,
you know,
and I'm not being sarcastic about that.
That question is not answerable without
some additional information about what
you're up to because it's like saying,
well our human languages the same or
different and the answer is,
well,
they're the same and different.
There are levels of analysis at which
they're the same and there are levels of
analysis at which they're different and
whether you consider the levels of
analysis with the similarities more
important than the levels of analysis
with the differences is going to depend
on what you want as a consequence of
asking the question.
So,
but we do know that there are broad and
identifiable similarities across people
that don't seem to be merely biological.
They're also biological and cultural and
you know,
you can see examples of that pretty
quickly by the fact that,
you know,
I think there are going to be more
smartphones in the world next year.
Then there are people and so it's pretty
obvious that there's a universal market
for smartphones and that says something
about,
you know,
that says something about the makeup of
people themselves regardless of culture.
Because people find tools that
facilitate social communication
desirable and they find tools that
facilitate information gathering
desirable and they don't have to be
taught to desire that they are just like
that.
So anyways,
so like I said,
piaget is a good antidote to moral
relativism because the idea that it's
like this,
think about it this way because this is
another way to understand it.
Um,
I'll give you two examples.
There were multiplayer online games in
the early stages of multiplayer online
games that collapsed into anarchy and
then they had to be shut down.
And the reason for that was that they
weren't playable games.
There was,
there was some flaw in their underlying
set of assumptions that made them
unsustainable as a meeting place for
multiple human beings across large
periods of time.
Others are more,
others are more calibrated and people
will play them.
So you can also think about a game as an
equilibrium state for example.
And,
and Piaget is quite smart about this
sort of thing.
So let's say a monopoly game.
Well,
is it an equivalent rated state?
While the answer to that is yes,
in so far as all the players finished
the game and then you might.
Well,
all the players finished the game and
they're still friends,
you know,
because that would be another level of
specification or constraint that you
could put on it.
But it's also interesting if you
consider something like an enjoyable
game as an equilibrated estate that you
can have competition within an
equilibrated status social community
with no problem.
As long as everybody agrees on what the
rules for the competition are,
you know,
on.
So Piaget actually regarded competition
as necessary element of games because he
said that game,
it's very so interesting.
He actually thought of competition in
some sense as a necessary as necessarily
tied in with with cooperation.
So here's an example,
take a hockey game.
So then we could say,
well,
our people in the playing hockey,
are they competing?
Are they cooperating?
And the answer to that is,
well,
it's pretty hard to distinguish because
all the players within a given team are
cooperating in so far as they're given
team.
And what that means is that each player
is trying to climb the hierarchy of
competence within the team,
but at the same time maximizing the
probability that the team will be
successful across multiple games.
And so that means that there's a set of
constraints around how that player has
to interact with his teammates,
right?
He has to work in a manner that enables
the development of his teammates because
otherwise it's a,
it's like a psychopathic strategy,
it's a bad longterm strategy.
And then you might say,
okay fine,
fine,
people are cooperating within the team,
but what about between teams?
And then the answer to that is while
they're cooperating,
insofar as they follow the rules,
you know,
and that they don't bring a basketball
to the hockey game or a set a chess set
to the hockey game because obviously you
can't play chess in hockey at the same
time.
And so everybody's agreed to act out a
certain set of behavioral risk
constraints.
And in so far as they're doing that,
that's a cooperative.
That's a cooperative maneuver.
So that's pretty.
That's pretty interesting to.
Piaget actually believed that children
couldn't become social until so at the
earliest stages of development as far as
piaget was concerned.
Children in some sense we're playing by
themselves and the reason they're doing
that is because they're not very
organized yet.
Their bodies are sort of not completely
under their control.
So you could think of a child as a non
equilibrated set of quasi functional and
cause I unified knowledge subsystems.
So for example,
when a child is born and they're laying
on their back,
their arms are kind of floating around
like this and the reason for that is
their arms aren't myelinated yet.
The but babies kind of myelinated from a
nervous system perspective in the center
of its body and its mouth is pretty
wired up,
but the rest of it isn't very formed.
And so what the child has to do is
integrate him or herself as an
individual entity and bring all those
subsystems online and into something
that's sort of integrated across
reasonable lengths of time.
And then the next goal is to do that
with someone else.
And that's about three years old when
social place starts.
So then if you and I are playing and
we're playing,
say pretend play,
we're going to say,
well we're going to do x,
we'll lay out the ground rules,
we're going to do x and we can compete
to get to towards x.
But if we couldn't have unified our
goals,
so unified these frames of reference,
we wouldn't be able to compete in the
same space.
And so one of the things piaget is
pointing out is that it's clearly the
case that a competitive game can
facilitate cooperation and in fact the
establishment of such games might
actually be absolutely fundamental to
socialization itself.
So you know,
because well,
you don't just want a game that
everybody can play.
I don't think so.
I don't think that's sufficiently
motivating for people you want to game
that everyone can play,
that everyone has a chance at winning
because playing is something that's for
sure.
And if it's a good game,
just playing it as interesting.
But winning is also something.
And so that places another constraint on
those games that people find that people
are willing to voluntarily play.
You know,
in one of the things that you can think
about with regards to the 20th century
is that the 20th century was an
experiment in producing games that were
predicated on rational assumptions about
the nature of mankind.
So for example,
the Communists said well,
from each,
according to his ability to each
according to his need,
which sounds like a pretty reasonable
proposition.
Right?
So you should work as hard as you can
and,
and give what you can to the community
and if you need something from the
community than it should be given to you
and you think,
well,
you know,
that seems like a pretty positive
presumption.
You know,
when there were other presumptions that
went along with the theory as well.
Like the fact that private property was
something that was a scourge and,
and,
and to be eliminated.
And so,
you know,
lots of societies set that game up as a
experiment in some sense.
And we found out very,
very rapidly that it didn't work.
So all games are not equally playable.
And that's a,
that's a,
a proposition that you can use to orient
yourself in a world where people talk
about the relativism of different moral
beliefs.
Now obviously there's some relativism
because in our society,
for example,
you can do perfectly well playing the
plumber game or playing the lawyer game
and the plumber game and a lawyer Gamer,
obviously different.
It all sorts of levels of analysis and
you know,
those are modes of being,
you can think of them in some senses.
Moral systems and both of them can
operate in the same environment.
So even in an elevated state,
there's room for a fair bit of
variability.
But it's variability within boundaries.
Just like the play when you're playing a
complex game is variable within
boundaries,
you know,
in most games that are enjoyable to play
multiple times,
set out some pretty serious constraints.
But within that system of constraints,
they enable a lot of freedom.
So.
Alright,
so you know,
that's,
that's an overview of Piagetian theory.
I mean,
I'm particularly interest with regards
to this course in Piaget's theories of
moral development.
And I outlined them in some sense right
there.
So,
you know,
one of the things that would happen is
that once a Nyquil abraded state is set
up at multiple levels of analysis,
the child's job is to interact with the
environment in a manner that doesn't
disrupt,
celebrate the systems that the child is
part of.
And you can think about that as
socialization,
you know,
and so for,
in this situation,
for example,
the only reason that this class can go
ahead without interruption is that
you're all playing and equilibrated
game,
roughly speaking,
you don't have to be here,
but you are.
And there's a whole large number of
unwritten procedural rules for being
here and you're all following them.
You know,
when you can think about that as a
consequence of some degree of tyranny.
And people have made that comment about
classrooms and sometimes it's true,
but you can also think about it as a
pretty successful equilibrated state
because universities have been around
for a thousand years,
you know,
and they've continued to cross time.
So it looks like a,
it looks like a pretty good game.
So yeah,
the trick is,
is that the value systems emerge as a
consequence of multiple constraints laid
down by the fact that there are multiple
levels of reality that have to be
harmoniously working simultaneously and
you know you're biologically celebrated
system in so far as you're healthy,
right?
Because,
well,
none of your,
none of your DNA has decided to make a
go of it on its own,
which is basically what happens when you
develop cancer and so it's a stacking of
systems on top of one another so that
each is nested in the other and they're
all working together and it's,
as you can imagine,
that's a very,
very tight set of constraints and
there's certainly lots of situations
where none of those are going to be met.
So
what's your motivation for learning?
This fits very well into cybernetic
models of,
of learning as well.
While you're motivated to learn what you
do doesn't produce what you want it to
do.
So that's another,
that's another description of
pragmatism.
Fundamentally.
So remember this is an action oriented
theory.
You're specifying the outcome and then
you're acting on the world in order to
bring it about and if it doesn't work
then you have to reexamine your
assumptions and then.
Or it's funny,
you have to reexamine your assumptions,
which would be part of a combination
because you'd be shifting around the
assumptions of the theory within which
you're operating,
but you're also going to be assimilating
information to.
So for example,
you know,
if you,
maybe you're 15 or 16 and you've tried
to establish a relationship with someone
that you have a romantic interest in and
that's failed multiple times.
Well the first thing is it's obvious
that you're,
you're the set of assumptions that
you're bringing to bear on the situation
are,
are inaccurate,
and you might say,
well,
what's the evidence that they're
inaccurate?
And the answer is,
well,
you aren't engaging in any romantic
relationships and that's the whole point
of the theories.
So they're inaccurate in so far as
they're not producing the desired
outcome.
Okay?
So then you might say,
well,
what could you do about that?
And one would be,
well you could gather some more
information.
So one of the things I do with my
clients,
for example,
if they happen to be terrified of the
opposite sex,
which is you know,
generally is a very high probability a
situation.
I often get them to go to speed dating
games because they can interact with 20
people in this space of an hour or two
and it expands their knowledge of
interactions and also their knowledge of
the variability of the people that
they're dealing with.
And so it's.
It's a form of exposure.
So you could say if you're using the old
kind of habituation theory,
you could say,
well,
they're just getting accustomed to the
situation,
but that's rubbish.
That isn't what they're doing at all.
What they're doing is going in there and
they're interacting and each time they
interact,
they gather more information and then
what did they do with that information
while they build it into themselves.
And that means that they start behaving
differently and they start
conceptualizing themselves in the world
differently.
And so some of it's built in at a
procedural level,
which means maybe they become more fluid
and less awkward in their nonverbal self
presentation.
But at the same time,
they're also incorporating abstract
knowledge that's going to help them
expand their domain of competence.
And so for Piaget,
the motive is if it doesn't work well,
then you should be motivated to fix it.
Now you know,
that doesn't work under all
circumstances because sometimes if it
doesn't work,
it crushes,
you know?
And so,
well that's something else we'll talk
about here.
So,
okay,
so this little diagram kind of points
out a little more complicated version of
that.
So you're going from point a which is
the unbearable present to point b,
and there's more or less two things that
can happen and one is what you want to
have happened and the other is something
other than you want happens.
Now,
sometimes the thing that you,
that happens that you don't want to
happen is minor,
in which case you can just modify,
you don't have to change your whole
theory,
you can just modify one tiny sub element
of it and you'll get where you're going.
So for example,
if I wanted to walk towards that set of
doors there and I was going to do it
blindfolded and I wasn't aware of this
environment,
I would walk forward until I encountered
a desk say,
and then I could just feel my way around
the desk and continue forward so I
wouldn't have to disrupt the whole plan.
I would just have to alter my core
elements of it.
But if I'm going to med school
hypothetically and I write the AMCAP and
I get 30th percentile,
which 30 percent of the people get or
lower,
right?
Then you're not going to medical school
and so that requires a radical revamping
of the of the system that you're using
to Schema ties your world and you know,
you might say,
well that would be motivating to.
That would motivate you to see what you
did wrong and to change it.
So you could go to medical school,
but sometimes it's just hopeless.
What you do,
this is a radical act of accommodation
is you do something else.
You know when you might go through an
intervening period of tremendous chaos.
Well,
every thing has fallen apart into its
subsidiary elements and you have no idea
how to unify that once again into a
calibrated state,
so,
so the diagram here shows you point a
and point b.
It says when you're going to point a
then what you want can happen and that's
great because you move forward.
Plus you validate the whole theory or
you can move forward and something that
you don't unexpect don't expect happens
and you don't understand it and that
stops you and if it's bad enough,
it invalidates the whole theory.
Now you might ask,
well,
what's the difference between a small
disruption and a large disruption?
And that's a very complicated thing to
figure out,
but it took me a long time to figure
this out.
I would say it probably took 20 years is
that
you could imagine that each of your,
your Schema,
your systems about adaptation work in a
given area and across a variety of
circumstances.
Okay.
Then you could say the most fundamental
assumptions that you have are the ones
that for you have worked across the
broadest possible range of situations
and time spans.
So they work when you're alone,
they work with,
when you're with other people,
they work in the short term and they
work in the longterm.
If you disrupt a Schema that Schema that
has oriented you across wide swaths of
time and space,
then that's really going to dysregulate
you emotionally.
Whereas if you disrupt the Schema that's
only locally operating,
like the table example that I gave you,
well it doesn't spread much.
It's you can make a minor adjustment
that's only relevant to this time and
place and it produced a little burst of
emotion.
Sometimes even positive emotion because
you just get curious about it instead of
frightened.
So,
and I can,
I'll show you as we proceed a little
more formal way of Schema enticing,
not because when you're reading piaget,
you might ask,
well at what point does assimilation
become accommodation?
And the answer that I just provided,
which I hope is reasonably
comprehensible is,
is the best I can provide.
Here's a more concrete way of looking at
it.
You're a premed student or let's do
prelaunch because let's pick on the pre
law students instead.
You're a pre law student.
So we can imagine that there's
assumptions that go into that.
Think about them all.
You're reasonably intelligent,
you're reasonably verbally intelligent,
you're going to do well on the Lsat,
there's going to be a career as a lawyer
waiting for you if you do well.
I'm
being a lawyer is a perfectly valid way
of being in the world from a moral and
practical perspective.
Being a lawyer is better than any other
way of being in the world because other
for you anyways,
because otherwise why wouldn't you pick
that?
Okay,
so those are pretty fundamental
assumptions and then you can think,
well,
how much of your Schema do they
underlie?
Well,
your judgement about your intelligence
and let's say also your relative ability
because you know,
ability isn't only intelligence,
that's a big one,
right?
You bring that with you pretty much
wherever you go.
There may be some domains where you
think,
well,
I'm not as smart as I could be there,
but it's usually quite a general
assumption.
And so let's say you write the Olsat sat
and you just bomb out.
It's like,
looks like you're not as smart as you
thought you were,
and so then what do you do about that?
Well,
it's rough because you not only do have
to reconstitute your vision of the
future,
but you have to reconstitute your vision
of the present and the past.
All those times that you thought you
were so smart,
it turns out you weren't.
So you can see that that's because of
those.
Those presuppositions are so fundamental
that disrupting them is going to produce
a fair degree of negative emotion.
So and you can tell from from this
diagram,
you imagine that when you're moving
forward from point a to point b,
there are.
There are obstacles that you can
encounter that you know of and you can
just put a detour in place.
Are there obstacles that emerged that
you have no idea how to conceptualize
whatsoever?
That often happens to people if they
develop the symptoms of a very serious
disease or if someone they love develop
severe the symptoms of a very serious
disease because not only are you not
going where you thought you were with
the person that you thought you were
going,
but you don't know what's going to
happen in the interim.
So it's very,
very difficult to accommodate to that.
And so one of the things I think that
piaget missed,
at least to some degree,
is that there's often catastrophic
discontinuity in this stage progression,
you know,
and he was looking at little kids and
how they put their cognitive schema
together and generally they're not
completely distraught and destroyed by
the necessity for transformation into
purely cognitive realm.
But,
uh,
well I told you,
I think I told you my nephew,
his dream about the dragon.
Did I tell you that?
Yeah.
Okay.
So he was going through a stage
transition at that point because while
there were two things happening,
one was that he was going off to
kindergarten.
That's a big deal.
And then there was some instability in
his family.
And so he had to figure out how to cope
with both of those,
and one of the ways of coping was to
become more of an individual and his
dream,
first of all,
laid out for him.
The problem,
the problem was there were problems.
Those are all the little bitey things
that were jumping up on them,
their problems.
But that's not the problem.
The problem is is that the problems keep
coming.
So not only are there problems,
but there's an indefinite number of them
and there's something that generates
them.
It's like the hydro.
You remember the Hydra in ancient
mythology,
it's got seven had to see cut off one
head,
seven more heads grow.
It's like,
that's life.
So you know what do you do under those
situations?
And he had this symbolic notion first in
the dream or the white triggered that
with my questions,
which was what?
You go right for the source of the
problems and you do something about
that.
Now,
part of the reason that Piaget thought
that the study of knowledge was best
construed as the study of the
acquisition of knowledge is because you
could say,
well,
here's the situation.
Do you know what to do?
And you say,
yes.
I say great,
no problem in that situation,
but then I could say,
here's the situation and you don't know
what to do.
Well that's a problem,
but that's also the problem of life and
so what's the solution to the set of
problems that you have no answer to and
the answer to that is assimilation and
accommodation,
exploration,
assimilation and accommodation.
Now when the little guy and the dream
went down the dragons throat,
he went to where the fire came out and
you can imagine that if a dragon is
belching,
fire and smoke and that's turning into
little,
you know,
beat demons,
that the fire box,
which is a place of transformation seems
to be the core of the problem.
Well,
he went to the core of the problem and
he cut part of it out and then you use
that as a shield.
Now that it's a brilliant solution
because basically what it proposes is
that
there's enough information in the world
and you're a good enough information
processor so that if you use all the
information that's lying latent in the
world against the set of all possible
problems,
it will work and I would say,
you know,
we have lots of clinical evidence that
that's the case because one of the
things we do for people in clinical
psychology all the time is,
well,
they have a problem.
We unpack it into the things that are
stopping them that they don't think they
can master.
And then we put them in a situation
where they're asked to develop mastery
over just those situations.
And it works.
And if you do an analysis of why it
works,
it's not exactly that.
They become less afraid.
So let's say somebody is agoraphobic and
they don't want to go in an elevator and
you teach them to go into the elevator.
You might say,
well,
they're less afraid of the elevator,
but it's not exactly right.
What they are is more confident in their
ability to be the sort of creature that
can overcome fears and prevail and
therefore go in the elevator.
So instead of the world getting less
dangerous,
they get braver,
which is a much better solution because
the world is just not going to get any
less dangerous.
So,
so the knowledge acquisition process is
explore in the face of novelty.
And the novelty is technically when you
lay out something that you think,
you know,
and something else happens in step.
So
this is a set of ideas that's in keeping
with,
uh,
Piaget's pragmatic viewpoint because a,
see,
sorry about that.
So you might say,
well,
if you're,
if you're basing your theory of
knowledge on action,
what are the elements of that theory of
knowledge?
Because they're not exactly objects
because objects or something that sort
of exist outside the realm of what
you're going to do with them.
At least in principle.
One of the presuppositions of science is
that the object exists independently of
its value.
But if your cognitive schemer are more
or less action predicated,
then that isn't exactly how the world
manifests itself to you,
not as an objective reality.
And here's a way of looking at it.
You're going from point a to point b.
and what do you see while you can look
at it in different ways,
uh,
these are ideas that are taking taken
from an ecological approach to visual
perception,
which was written byj dot j dot Gibson,
who's,
who has constructivist elements in his
thinking.
So he would say that when you,
when you look at the world,
what you see are things that will
facilitate your movement forward.
Roughly speaking,
those are tools,
although he would have called them
affordances.
It's kind of a broader category,
but no one knows what affordances means.
So I'm going to use tools and the later
scientists like Jeffrey Gray pointed out
that if you see something that
facilitates movement forward,
that produces positive emotion.
So for example,
if I want to go up to that exit sign and
I see that pathway clear as it is now,
that's going to produce a little
approach.
Activation in me and make me feel good,
whereas if people have put six or seven
pack sacks in the way and I look at
that,
that's going to produce a bit of
negative emotion right away because the
other thing that you see in the world
are obstacles,
tools,
facilitators,
affordances,
depending on how you look at it and
obstacles and you manifest positive
emotion to the tools and negative
emotion to the obstacles.
And then there's another class which is
things that you don't know,
things you don't,
things you aren't able to classify as
tools or obstacles but that aren't
irrelevant.
And that's a class of unexpected things.
Now,
along with tools and obstacles,
there's another rule which is you ignore
almost everything,
right?
You ignore almost everything.
So most things have no value at all.
And the value is actually dependent to
some degree on the Schema that you lay
on the situation.
So.
Alright,
so
I'll tell you about this too.
So here's a.
here's a more elaborated description of
what happens to you when you run into
something that you don't know what to do
with.
Because remember,
you have to deal with the things that
you don't know how to deal with,
which is a very peculiar problem because
obviously you don't know how well what
happens is that your body has default
responses and one of the default
responses is that you freeze because you
tend to respond to anything that's
unexpected as if it has a predatory
impulse.
You know,
so you're back on the Velt,
you know,
6 million years ago and you hear
something rustling in the bushes.
It's probably a or in the grass.
It's probably a pretty good idea to
freeze because perhaps it's a Predator
and you don't want to attract its
attention.
So one of the things that your body
does,
two things.
You don't expect this to treat them as
if they're predatory and you as if
you're prey.
So you freeze and then you ramp up your
physiology so your heart rate will go
up,
for example,
and you might say,
well,
your heart rate goes up because you're
afraid.
It's like,
well no,
that isn't why your heart rate goes up.
Your heart rate goes up so that your
heart pumps blood to your muscles and
when you're afraid you want to have
blood pumped to your muscles because you
want to use the damn things for running
away or fighting if you have to.
And so that's why.
For example,
if you do psychophysiological
experiments,
you can't just assume that raised heart
rate rate means fear because it might
mean excitement or any number of other
things.
What it really means is that you're
preparing to act well and so how do you
prepare to act if you don't know what to
do and the answer is you pretty much
prepared to do anything
and that's really hard on you and if you
stay in,
if you stay in the mode of preparing to
do anything for a long period of time,
then you age and you're more likely to
become diabetic and you're more likely
to become obese and you're more likely
to get cancer and infectious diseases
and so on and so forth.
Because,
well,
partly because your body suppresses your
immune system while you're in the state
of not knowing what to do next.
Because you know if,
if you have to fight with the tiger in
the next five minutes,
doesn't really matter if you're going to
die of smallpox in a year,
so your body just shuts off everything
that isn't useful,
so and then you might think about that
as stress and that's pretty good way of
thinking about stress and then you might
assimilate that to dominance hierarchies
and here's how you could do it at the
top of the dominance hierarchy.
Everything you do works.
That's why you were at the top of the
dominance hierarchy at the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy.
Nothing you do works.
That's why you're at the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy.
Now,
that might be the fault of the dominance
hierarchy,
but as far as you're concerned,
it's irrelevant because the point is
what's it doing to you?
And the answer is if you're at the
bottom of the dominance hierarchy,
you don't know what's going to happen
next.
And so you're always in a state of
chronic preparation for activity and
that's why you die sooner and you're
more likely to develop infectious
diseases and all sorts of things.
And that's even true if you control for
absolute income.
So
all right,
so that's kind of what this diagram
indicates.
So this is,
this is similar to the initiation
rituals that we talked about before.
You're in a Schema and something comes
along and knocks out one of the
presuppositions.
So what you're doing doesn't work.
Then you're going to fall into an
intermediate period of chaos and the
chaos is going to be proportionate to
the importance of the proposition that
that was disrupted and the importance is
going to be proportionate to how much
you use that axiom across multiple
situations.
So you know,
I can give you a scientific example.
You may remember,
perhaps not a couple of years ago,
there was a report from someone in
Europe that they had managed faster than
light communication.
Now the right response to that was no
way,
because that means the most fundamental
physical theory we have that's passed
like 50,000 other tests is wrong.
So when they say,
well,
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence.
But had it been true,
it would have been earth shattering
because it would mean that the physical
theory that physicists use not only to
ramp up their career but to actually
deal with the world had a fundamental
axiomatic error,
you know,
and it turned out that there was
something wrong with their measurements,
which is,
you know,
one of the problems when something
unexpected occurs,
right?
You don't know if it's some damn trivial
thing because you haven't calibrated the
machine properly or whether you've just
discovered,
you know,
when new part of the secret to the
universe.
So generally you should assume that
you've calibrated your machine
improperly.
And I should also tell you something
about something that's akin to that
from,
with regards to a self protective mode
of reconstructing your Schema.
So one of the things that happens to
depressed people is something like this.
So maybe they go out and,
you know,
they try to have a conversation with
someone in a coffee shop and you know,
maybe that person's having a horrible
day or maybe you know,
they're very disagreeable and
extroverted,
which makes them kind of narcissistic.
And so there route and the depressed
person thinks I'm,
I can't talk to people.
It's bad people that can't bad,
useless people,
can't talk to people.
I'm a bad,
useless person.
I've always been a bad,
And as far as I can tell,
I'm going to be a bad,
useless person as far as I can see into
the future.
Well,
you could say,
well,
what's wrong with that?
Because it's true.
Maybe it's true.
Maybe the reason the person won't talk
to you is because like,
you're just wrong in a million different
ways,
but let's not jump to conclusions.
So the rule there,
the mental hygiene rule is picked the
simplest possible explanation and until
you disprove that accepted and one of
them would be,
well you know,
that person's probably not having such a
good day,
or maybe that person's not having such a
you know?
Or maybe if I smiled at them a little
more brightly and somewhat less
pathologically,
they would have talked to me.
You know?
So this is important to remember when
you make mistakes in your life,
don't start out with generic high level
criticisms.
You know,
it's a pathway to self-destruction,
assume minor alterable changes until
proven until it's proven otherwise.
So anyways,
it's a big problem because it's not that
easy to figure out why,
where the mistake is when you make a
mistake that stops you from getting what
you want.
Yes,
yes it is.
It's the alchemist razor on the value on
the value side of the equation.
Assume a small error.
Assume a small repairable error.
And then if that doesn't work out,
then as soon as slightly large
repairable error.
And I'll show you a Schema for
understanding that in a minute that's
akin to Piaget's construction of the
world from the bottom up.
So let me show you that
here.
It's a very helpful diagram.
I think I can find it.
Alright,
we're going to go at this a couple of
different ways.
So
look at the top
diagram.
It's a hierarchy,
right?
So you might say,
what does it mean
to be a good person?
And you might think,
well,
you know,
that's an empirical question,
but from the [inaudible] or the
pragmatic perspective,
that's not exactly right because what
being a good person is and is an
abstract representation of an
aggregation of action oriented behaviors
in presuppositions that have the
similarity across context.
Now we're going to decompose it.
So this is for say an adult of about 35.
What's one element of being a good
person?
While you might say being a good parent,
it's not a necessary element,
but you know,
it's one of the ones that would fit
there.
So what does it mean to be a good
parent?
While you could say roughly speaking
that you have a good job and that you
take care of your family and then you
might say,
well,
what does it mean to take care of your
family?
Now,
one of the things I would like you to
note is that these are abstractions,
right?
Good person,
good parent,
take care of your family.
There are abstractions.
The question is what do they represent
or what are those abstractions made up
of?
Now,
lots of the abstractions that are,
that we use are made up of descriptions
of the world,
so scientific categories are like that,
but these aren't scientific categories.
There are categories,
so they're actually made up of actions
not have object facts,
objective facts.
They're not made out of objective
material at all.
There are a whole different thing.
Good person,
good parent,
take care of your family.
Okay?
What does it mean to take care of your
family?
Well,
there's a bunch of things that means,
but one of them might be your cooked
meals and you play with the baby.
Okay,
so then,
well,
what does it mean to complete a meal?
Well,
it looks like in this example you're
cooking corn.
So what do you have to do?
You have to cut it.
You have to set the table,
you have to do dishes.
Now you can imagine you could decompose
those two.
What do you have to do if you're doing
the dishes?
Well,
you have to grip a dish.
You have to move your hand in a twisting
motion.
You have to push this arm forward and
turn on the tap.
Okay,
so what's cool about that is you can see
where the mind,
which is the part of us that's capable
of abstract considerations,
meets the body,
right?
Because people are always wondering,
well,
how do you solve the mind body problem?
While this is one of the ways you solve
that,
you assume that abstract categories are
actually abstract representations of
patterns of action and then you
decompose them till you get to that
action.
It's like,
how do you go underneath this?
What's next on the hierarchy?
Well,
it doesn't matter because you're not
conscious of it anyways.
It's muscle movements.
It's cell,
it's electrical information that your
cells are sharing.
It's completely irrelevant to you.
It's not part of your consciousness.
This is you can do this.
You can't move a thing.
You know you can't move an identifiable
finger myself because you don't know
which ones they are.
So one of the things piaget would point
out is that one,
one of the characteristics of a baby
when the baby's first born is that it
has.
It can do these sorts of things.
It comes equipped to do these sorts of
things.
Those are basic reflexes.
Now there are more basic than this,
but a child can do this and can stick
out its tongue,
which is really helpful because that
means that it can mouth everything in
its vicinity,
which is exactly what a child does and
the reason it does that is because this
little exploratory apparatus here is
quite wired up and so what the child
assumes,
so to speak first is the world is a
place to put in your mouth and that's
why babies are always putting everything
they can in their mouth.
Now you know the tongue is absolutely
covered with sensory and motor nerves,
so it's unbelievably,
unbelievably fast style exploratory tool
and so the child starts to extract out
information about the world by using
its.
Its oral reflex is to a large degree to
begin with.
Now it can also move its eyes,
although it's not really quite so good
about that and you know because it's
eyes cross a fair,
Beth.
It takes a while to get both of them
coordinated.
You can hear things and so on.
It's got a sense of touch.
So,
but it's equipped to start operating on
the world at the highest resolution
level of analysis.
So we could say think about it this way,
as you move up a chain of abstractions,
your representations get lower and lower
in resolution.
I understand.
So for example,
being a good person is a much lower
resolution description than picking up a
fork prior to setting it on the table.
Although picking up a fork is a micro
element of being a good person.
So that's a high resolution description.
So another thing that you can know is
that if you make a mistake,
try to decompose the problem into high
resolution representations.
It's lazy not to,
not only that,
it's insulting.
So you know,
you come home and maybe your partner has
agreed to make a meal and the thing is
like scorched to death,
you know,
and so you say you are not a good
person,
you've never been a good person and
you're never going to be a good person.
It's like,
well they're not a good person in so far
as they weren't able to,
you know,
make the meal.
But you could start with a micro
analysis,
it's like why exactly did that burn
since that's not the desired outcome,
you know,
and then you can help the person
disentangle the sequence and you can
find out where the error occurred.
Now maybe they were distracted by
something else or whatever.
But it's,
it's a very difficult analytic process.
But I can tell you if you're going to
maintain an equilibrium state with
yourself and with people around you,
stay away from the low resolution
abstractions.
When you're discussing something
important,
go down to the micro level,
you know.
So here's an example that you might
consider with regards to children as
they develop.
So the baby's laying on his crib on its
back,
you know,
when it's trying to get its act together
and it's going to organize its arms and
its got to organize its legs and its got
to figure out how to move them because
it's just hitting them,
hitting itself in the head with its
arms.
Piaget would say child will be laying
there and go like this.
And that'll sort of startle them.
And then one of the things they'll do is
try to do it again.
So in that way the child uses imitation
of itself to start building up the basis
of predictability.
It's bloody brilliant idea,
you know,
so.
So that's part of the groundwork that
the child lays to start understanding
the world is going to be putting things
in its mouth and then it's gonna notice
similarities between the way something
feels and how it feels when it's in the
mouth and it's going to notice that this
motion is good for grabbing bottles,
but it's also good for grabbing like
teddy bears.
So maybe teddy bears and bottles are in
the same category to begin with.
And the category is things you can grab
and bring close to you,
you know,
which is a perfectly reasonable
category.
So it's not an objective category and
the child is changing all these things
together and developing more and more
sophisticated abilities with its body.
And at the same time because it becomes
more facile with its body,
it can analyze the world at a higher and
higher level of resolution.
And so it's the circular process.
Information in development of tools,
expansion of knowledge,
information,
development of tools,
expansion of knowledge.
You sort of boost yourself up
fundamentally and you do it from the
bottom up.
Now,
let's say you've got a three year old.
This is a good example of how children
different different developmental
stages,
so maybe have a 15 year old.
You say,
clean up your room.
Now.
That is a low resolution
representations.
Now when you use that low resolution
representation on the 15 year old,
you assume that they know the following
things,
so we're going to put that aside for a
moment.
Now you're talking to a three year old
and you're in their room and the room is
scattered with junk because they'd been
played and you say,
now it's time to clean up your room and
then you leave and then you come back in
20 minutes and what's happened?
No,
the child is playing with some toy and
you say,
you know,
didn't you hear what I said?
And the answer to that is while I heard
it,
but I didn't have any idea what you
meant and the reason that I didn't have
any idea what humanity is because I
don't have the microprocesses embodied
in me.
So they need to take the three year old
and you say,
do you see your bare?
And the child goes,
yes,
because they've got seeing down you
point.
They can see what you're pointing at.
Great.
That's a little micro routine.
And then you say,
couldn't you go pick up that bear?
And they know that one too.
So then they'll go pick up the bear and
then you might point to a spa space on
the shelf that's empty.
And you could say,
well could you put that bear in that
space?
And they've got that too.
So then you want to help them clean up
the room,
but you don't want to do it for them.
Well,
what do you do?
You build up all the micro routines and
it's painstaking,
Hey,
if you're a parent,
you're just going to think,
well go play all cleaned up the room.
But then you'll be cleaning it up until
the child is 15 because they won't
develop the micro routines,
so you might as well just start right
off the bat and go through the
painstaking process of building up the
procedural knowledge as the ground for
the abstract conceptions because the
next time the child you want the child
to clean up the room,
you could start by saying,
pick up the toys on the floor and put
them where there is space on the shelf
and maybe they've generalized across
those,
you know,
more concrete instances of cleaning up
so that they can use the abstract
representation to govern themselves.
So this also helps you figure out what
it means for something to mean
something.
He might say,
well that's meaningful for what?
What does that mean?
Well,
it means that partly it means that you
have the underlying structure so that
you can take the abstract utterance and
decompose it into actionable sequences
in the world.
Now,
sometimes meaningful also means you
could use the information to rate,
configure the abstractions that you use
to guide action in the world.
So that's a bit more complicated.
But you get the point now,
part of the reason we can communicate,
and this is quite interesting and this
is sort of in keeping with Piaget's
ideas,
is I kind of knew what you know now.
Why do I know that?
Well,
it's because it's not because I know you
because I don't,
but it's because you're like me a lot.
I mean physiologically we're not clones,
but the similarities are obviously there
so I can assume that you have some
relationship with your body that more or
less parallel is the relationship I have
with my body and then I can also assume
that since that the environment you grew
up in was sufficiently similar to the
environment that I grew up in,
so that the Schema of actions and
abstractions that constitutes your
personality is similar enough to mind so
that I can use abstractions and you'll
know what they mean.
And so it's a very complex and
sophisticated theory of communication,
right?
Because it assumes that,
well,
where is the meaning in a word?
The word is embedded in the phrase and
the phrase is embedded in that sentence
and so on,
so that's complicated,
but the meaning is,
is that I compress a whole sequence of
action strategies and representational
Schema is into a phrase and I toss it to
you and you decompose it and then you've
got the meaning,
you know,
in some,
some like you can't do something like,
well,
how do you play the piano while you sit
in front of it?
Move your hands up and down the keys.
Right?
That's too low resolution to be useful,
but especially if I know that you don't
know how to play the piano,
but if,
if I can assume sufficient shared
experience and shared biological
commonality,
then I can use high level abstractions
and we can exchange information.
So.
All right,
so the PSD and notion,
at least in part,
is that
you're interacting with the world
constantly and you're doing that in
order to extract out from the world what
you need and to increase your competence
at getting what you need.
Right?
So that's a cool idea too.
So,
and here is a way of understanding that
way of understanding,
of celebrated states at a high level of
abstraction.
So think about this.
So
your kids in a soccer game and uh,
let's say trip someone in elbows with
them and the referee doesn't catch on
and their team wins the game and maybe
their team wins the game because he
tripped him and elbowed him and the kid
comes off the court,
the pitch.
Yes.
And says we won.
And what do you say?
Well,
if you're like 30 percent of the soccer
parents I saw you say,
good job,
you should have kicked them again,
but that,
that isn't what you shouldn't say.
Right?
You shouldn't say that's no way to win.
And then the question might be what in
the world do you mean by that?
Because as far as the child's concerned,
hypothetically,
they just one.
And that's the point of the game.
So when you say that's no way to win,
what do you mean?
Well,
think about it this way.
What's the definition of winning at
soccer?
Well,
one question is well,
winning the game.
Well,
yeah,
that's kind of,
that's a little too high resolution for
the current purposes.
Like how about um,
developing your skill as a physical
being,
Huh?
That's a good one.
Developing your skill in a physical
being as a physical,
being in a manner that will translate
into success in other domains of the
world,
that's even better.
You get to be well developed physically
and it works more places.
How about developing your physical
abilities in a manner that ensures that
lots of people invite you to play games
for the rest of your life?
That's a really good deal.
And so when you say,
well,
it doesn't matter whether you win or
lose,
it matters how you play the game.
What you're saying is the proper
equilibrated status,
not victory within a game.
It's
the ability to play many games and to
extract value from each instance of
playing.
And then you went across huge swaths of
time instead of sacrificing that to some
trivial local victory.
And that's another example of how
morality emerges from the bottom up,
from the games that people play.
So there's actions and then there's the
integration of actions.
And schema within yourself as an
individual.
Then you kind of got your act together
as a two to four year old and you better
have your act together by the time
you're for enough so that other children
will play with you because otherwise
you're basically screwed for life.
You cannot be fixed after that and
there's endless amounts of evidence
showing that so he kind of got yourself
together by the time year two to four
enough so that other people can tolerate
you and then you start playing games
with them and the Games are cooperative
and competitive and if you're good at
playing,
which means you are fair across multiple
instances of the game,
then you'll have lots of friends and
you'll be able to play with them and
then you'll have a whole network of
games which has all the games you play
with all your friends and all the
different circumstances.
And then you're going to learn how to be
a good player across all those games.
And hopefully the environment that
constitutes the shared elements of that
set of games is similar to the adult
environment.
That constitutes a whole set of things
that you'll do when you're an adult and
that'll mean that you're socialized
enough to start to develop some autonomy
and individuality and independence and
that's all emerging from the bottom up.
It's not a top down.
It's not instantiated from the top down.
It's a natural progression of moral
systematizing in society as a whole and
also a natural progression of your
adaptations to that system as you mature
and that in 90 minutes or thereabouts is
the essence of Piagetian theory and
there's some elements of a lot of what
you learn if you take piaget,
generally speaking is stage theory and
compared to what piaget was really up
to.
Stage theory is pretty much irrelevant
because what I laid out for you today
was really what he was up to and all the
things that he was doing in the multiple
publications that he laid out were
attempts to determine how does society
organizes itself from the bottom up and
how does the individual do the same
thing.
And it's extremely useful way of
thinking.
You know,
so.
And it will close with this from a
practical perspective because I try to
only teach you things that I think have
practical utility.
So that means if you know them,
you'll understand yourself and others
better and you'll get along with them
better and that the consequences of that
will be that you're better placed in the
social world and that'll make the social
world somewhat better.
So what's the take home message from
this?
Well,
one is the most important one I think is
don't use high level negative
abstractions to characterize your
behavior or that of others.
What you have to do is.
The thing is,
is that if you have someone,
for example,
maybe you have a roommate who can't
cook,
or maybe you are that roommate.
So like in order to help someone like
that,
you have to decompose the process until
you hit the level at which they're
competent.
And then you have to
teach them how to integrate those things
that they know into the next stage of
development.
So it's a complex decomposition and then
you were actually helpful.
And now you'll find when you have an
intimate relationship with someone that
you want to last over the long run,
I can give you a couple of hands.
One is do not use high level negative
abstractions.
They'll hate you and for good reason
because you're criticizing them in a
generic and stupid manner.
What you want to do is first of all,
help them identify the problem at the
highest level of resolution necessary
and then implement a solution that will
actually solve the problem.
Now that often takes a fair bit of
conflict and a fair bit of immediate
analysis.
It's difficult and so people will avoid
it,
but if you do that,
every time you do that and it works,
that's a problem you'll never have again
in your life.
That's a really good deal.
So it beats the hell out of ignoring it
and hoping that it'll go away.
So all right,
so we'll see you
Thursday.